- [Gary] You know what
I think hurts young people?
Pride.
- You think so.
- [Gary] Yeah, let me explain.
- I'm trying to put myself in
your nice shoes right now
and I'm saying, you know,
there's a part
of you that's like,
look, I don't want it
to just be homies
that he's gonna get me.
I'm gonna go get mine,
do my thing.
I actually think that's a
stunning vulnerability that
a lot of people
get caught on.
I think you should recruit
at Tennessee and hard.
And I don't know your Rolodex or
anybody else you played with or
your best friend
in the league or
who the fuck knows, right?
I really think that's a
really interesting thing
for you to debate.
You know, do you know
I spent my whole,
do you know even when,
this is gonna blow your mind
what I'm about to say.
Maybe AJ's the only
one that really knows this.
Do you know even
as you were about to say
what you're about to say
about my background
I didn't like it?
I know how great I am and
I wish my story was zero to 60,
not 3 to 60 because
then people could be like
well he had this.
I know what I am
and it sucks.
I used to cry,
I used to call my mother
and cry and be like nobody's
gonna ever give me credit.
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] You know this.
- [AJ] Yeah.
- [Gary] This was the biggest
fear of my life when
I knew I was special at 18,
like I'm gonna be it.
And so, what ends
up happening is
if you're good enough,
you're good enough.
I'm sure AJ had to deal with it
with VaynerMedia, right?
His brother was,
like what did he? You know?
I think pride, I think AJ is
very successful in life
because he knew how to
calibrate the good and the bad.
So I think when
you start something
there's going to
be a bunch of people
who if they don't
know anything about you,
you're 23, this and that.
You're not gonna
prove it to them, man.
- [AJ] Nah, impossible
no matter how smart you are.
I was in the boardroom
with C-suite executives at
every Fortune 500 but when
you're 23 walking into a room,--
- They're like get
the fuck out of here.
- you can't say anything.
- [Man] So the next
plan is just moving on?
- So I stay on moving on.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like I don't even start
to try to convince anybody.
I actually prefer
them not to believe
and then show them later.
Because you win
them over harder.
So what I would do,
if you were like my son or
brother, I'd be like listen,
"Here's what you do.
"Let's figure out,
when a man says brothers
"whatever he can
put you on to, great."
I don't know but whatever you
start with advantages with
your high school
coach taught this kid,
take up all those things.
- [Man] Right.
Because I'll tell you
some of the things that
I've done not well in my career
were I had too much
ego and pride and didn't
want to take the
easy thing, just stupid.
At the end of the day,
the net score is the net score.
So I would give that thought.
- [Man] Okay.